my name is moises name on the scene I am
a senior associate at the Carnegie
Endowment for international peace she's
a think tank in Washington I just shared
a session all the title how can latin
america best contribute to the global
governance system contribute to the
stability of the world one important or
answer to that question is by continuing
to do and to be what it is and what it
has been doing like in America what a
lot of countries were crashing
financially in few years ago 2007 2008
2009 all the problems that in America
was growing in fact Latin America
provided a source of growth and Brazil
and other countries were very important
in stabilizing a lot of variance stable
economies at the same time Latin America
does not have some of the very difficult
problems in terms of conflicts and
security nuclear weapons terrorism that
are now difficult in all in other
crippling their disability in other
countries so in many ways Latin America
contrary to what was the case in the
past has become a region that irradiate
stability and peace to the rest of the
world